that's Ranchos look at you now you know
dr. foster gentlemen Jack on HBO and yet
there was a time in your career well
maybe people don't predicted those
glistering Heights what are your first
job was it theater education was it
craggy CIA yeah crack rats chronograph
so crank rats would go around to schools
yeah and what would you what were you
teaching people so have you ever done
any T ie stuff no Tom School like they
do so you get your van and you get your
set and you get your costumes which
people have borrowed from all their
aunties and Nana's and stuff like that
bad wigs put it in the van go to all the
schools and we were teaching post
education options so we would go in and
set our thing up and then the 15 16 year
olds would come in to their assembly and
then and then I and my team would sing
songs to them about their options and
obviously have deeper chats as well but
it was it was like pop songs to let them
know their options one particular was an
S Club 7 song so we'd go in and sing
don't stop never gave our poet I am
reached the top we're all doing an NVQ
and working in a job
and then I mean to make it works like
that's not bad enough then then you give
out forms and you say so what did you
think of the crack rats because
obviously it's community thing you need
to give feedback and we'd go in the van
get our bodies from down the shop and a
mine would usually say the one with the
dark hair as big tits
it's a crag where so that's the company
that's the TI e company is yeah and what
did they mean when they picked crag rap
I have no idea more of your code young
people in their lives so you should call
it crag rap a diversity thing for bin
men it laughs burn yeah and we sang ABBA
songs yeah and that was you
[Laughter]
[Music]
you